laura ling du millage laquelle est mon
invité suivant luis fernandez
la poésie tout le monde oui
du coup je suis intimidée par pour
pourquoi il ya de la broye ya du lourd
la qualité et à jean marie allafort à
côté mais alors il ya des vies a ajouté
li atteindront guy à florent pb et après
et voilà est presque passée où sont les
400 millions bien luis bonsoir cet
entraîneur à l'athletic de bilbao
comment ça se passe et les ukrainiens ça
va ça va ça se passe pas trop mal
combien de championnats et 6e bien 6e
pas mal ouais mais c'est relativement
très serré un championnat très très dur
très dur très dur
vous restez athlétique oui je resigne
pour un an
très bien longtemps qu'est ce que c'est
qu'ils vous pourrez vous faire partir
pour l'instant rien du tout bon non
parce que je suis relativement
sélectionneur l'équipe de france
peut-être non c'était dans quelques
temps les peuples dans l'heure actuelle
vous laisser au jeu lui même fait un peu
jeune pour ça encore ils se postent la
dic et l'a sérieusement 40 ha oui c'est
pas vieux 40 dont vous êtes luis
fernandez on peut le dire une légende
je suis obligée non bâti une légende du
foot français par autant pas trop une
légende quoi c'est extraordinaire là
l'espagne et six enfants le père ouvrier
agricole qui meurt quand vous avez six
ans la france avec les cinq frères et
soeurs les minguettes
c'est un long parcours les minguettes et
puis vous avez dit je n'ai pas eu une
enfance heureuse
oui ça dans les rets l'histoire le fait
d'avoir une enfance mal en ce sens que
l'on entend par ne pas avoir une enfance
heureuse de mon enfance pour il ya des
bons et des mauvais moments mais alors
qu'ils avaient aussi bon quand vous
étiez petit au mag est ce que vous étiez
pas un gros voyou mon arrivée un peu de
un putsch ou à droite à gauche quoi vous
venir instant là de temps en parler
non mais je prends les paquets de
bonbons dans les étagères et paquet de
chocolats ou les 45 les 45 tours et 45
non 1 le seul rayon de soleil dans cette
vie là c'était donc les vacances à
tarifa quand vous partez en vacances
vous partiez c'était folklo ils
profitent les dissidents la 404 3 devant
trois derrière bien enseigner 2000km
offrir à la seconde au grand frère qui
en une seul truc que vous aimez restée
le football quoi juillet dans la cour de
votre celle aime chez nous et ses deux
passions pour foule
ça commence mal tout ça donc là je fais
là la légende de tce dans une soirée
légende donc 76,1 des mois mais j'aurais
dû faire tu avais jean-mi un nom unis ma
carrière ces emplois est comique très
vieux alors 76 et d'électricien trois
mille balles par mois ouais pas énorme à
l'époque c'était quand même et on vous
appelez quasimodo puisque vous étiez un
peu
goûter un peu mieux on prend de l'âge
alors vous cherchez un club parce que
vous étiez quand même le meilleur de
votre catégorie en foutent quoi vous
cherchez un club et vous prenez une
semaine pour venir à paris au psg ça
l'air de rien mais une semaine pour
venir rencontrer les gens du psg ça veut
dire une semaine sans boulot sans
salaire demandé la permission exactement
responsable et votre mère c'est naze et
pas spécialement mon arrivée ici
première chose escroqués par un taxi qui
fonctionne et à saint germain en relief
vers quatre fois le tour de la ville
c'est bien ça c'est ça tout à fait ça
donc en 85 capitaine du psg
oui et en 86 le matra racing by matra si
monsieur zuma jours à venir non non et
du tout non
si le club de lagardère vous passer de
25 mille balles le du pognon lagardère
de 25 mille balles par mois à 700 mille
balles par mois sept prix qui ressort à
l'époque aujourd'hui feront tous les cas
tout le monde fait aujourd'hui il le
faisait il ya dix ans il est en avance 1
était dans le vrai chemin
sept cent mille balles parce que vous
aviez commencé occasion j'organise à
700000 sérieux relativement aujourd'hui
ça passe comme une lettre à la vraie à
l'époque c'était pas du fer footballeur
oui je sais pour 5 10 ans de il y en a
qu'un qui gagne ça mais bon c'est pas
moi alors ça se passe pas si bien donc
lagardère vous disputez un peu avec
bien piètre homonymie avec mon amitié
partez à cannes
borelli la bugatti quatre fois moins oui
1,94 vous revenez au psg entraîneur et
en 96 ou par tel aviv
enfin 96 ou partez donc du psg après
avoir remplacé artur jorge en 97 points